de quoi est ce qu'on va parler
aujourd'hui
regardez ce que j'ai récupéré j'en ai
parlé à quelques jours j'ai fait un
homme boxing rapide vous avez vu ça
samsung galaxy fold le premier
smartphone pliable le smartphone de
samsung
et justement aujourd'hui un pouvoir en
parler on va se le faire en test vous
allez voir il ya plein de choses à dire
ça fait quelques jours que je lègue le
manipule venue d'alex et franchement il
est top
[Musique]
m
non non
[Musique]
alors y cyphose il est intéressant il
est cool et surtout il a un intérêt
principal c'est qu'il est tout nouveau
il ouvre la voie alors je sais les
smartphones à écran pliable vous en
parle depuis très longtemps
c'est vrai que ça fait des années et des
années que je vous parle de smartphones
à écran plat mais je suis très content
qu'il soit arrivé aujourd'hui et que je
puisse m'amuser avec ce petit objet la
petit à petit tout petit j'ai dû te
tiens au fait il pas du tout petit le
galaxy folk pop voilà je m'installe jeu
mais le niveau est alors je sais pas si
vous savez vous pas d'ailleurs dit moi
si ça vous intéresse est ce que le fait
d'avoir un smartphone à écran pliable
vous pensez qu'il ya un sens ou alors
est-ce que vous voyez pas encore tout de
suite l'intérêt si vous ne voyez pas
c'est peut-être qu'il est trop tôt c'est
trop tôt que marcher pas prêt mais
croyez-moi ça c'est l'avenir du
smartphone vous allez en voir de partout
de plus en plus et même d'ailleurs
l'année prochaine s'annonce on devrait
lancer plusieurs samsung galaxy folk un
modèle toujours très haut de gamme les
modèles plus accessibles
tu n'as pas pour les plus petites
bourses pour ça va quand même pour un
peu plus de 2000 euros là dessus en tout
cas smartphones que tout un chacun
pourrait potentiellement acheter
d'ailleurs si ça vous intéresse
dites le moi en bas en commentaire moi
je me sens vraiment cool pour l'avoir
testé pendant plusieurs jours si vous
assurer qu'il ya un vrai intérêt avec ce
smartphone il ya des points positifs il
ya aussi des points négatifs
il ya des choses qui vont pas la copie
n'est pas parfaite c'est un premier
modèle
je vais vous détailler tout ça mais
sachez que déjà moi j'aime beaucoup le
concept je le trouve vraiment top
et surtout ça apporte un vent de
fraîcheur un peu sur l'univers du
smartphone c'est tout nouveau et tout
beau et surtout le mot majeur je crois
que ce n' est confiant je vous ai déjà
montré la boîte le jour je ferai pas
l'affront de vouloir montrer bon allez
bien elle est sympa mais surtout le truc
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est cette
jolie petite bête alors jolie petite
bête est la désavantage comme vous lisez
les inconvénients le gros premier
inconvénient c'est quand même qu'il est
un peu épais un peu plus épais que ce
que votre ouvriers avec un smartphone un
petit peu son art puis surtout le
problème c'est son poids il fait
beaucoup plus de 200 grammes il fait
plus de 250 grammes il fait 2 164 g il
est quand même relativement long on le
sent on sent vraiment la différence
entre le galaxy folle et un smartphone
pas plus standard déjà quand vous aviez
ou quand vous avez un smartphone de plus
de 200 grammes vous trouvez lourd là le
galaxy foot douala ici c'est quand même
son petit poids on sent qu'il ya à côté
de ça peut pas faire de la magie non
plus vous avez quand même un smartphone
qui est grande
fatalement il faut bien pouvoir faire
quelque chose hors j'imagine que dans le
temps samsung et consorts probablement
la concurrence quand elle quand elle si
les tra arrivera à alléger un petit peu
le poids de ses smartphones mais bon
voilà il n'y a pas de magie non plus et
puis à noter qu'avec ce smartphone c'est
que il est un peu épais donc du coup
dans votre poche il s'y repère et
regardez je le prends je le mets là vous
voyez les déformations au niveau du
jeans alors déjà un smartphone normal ça
prend un peu de place mais là ça vous
fait une espèce de grandes bandes d'un
pantalon ou bien la mettre sur le côté
pour bien faire comprendre que c'est un
smartphone et non autre chose ça prend
un peu de place j'imagine que dans un
sac à main c'est pareil ça prendra de la
place mais dans un pantalon c'est là
c'est un peu déformant ça en tout cas
c'est un des points négatifs la prison
dans des mails va pas déranger ce plus
quand vous le prenez comme ça à une main
c'est vrai que ça m'a pas posé de
problème parce qu'il est très fin long
mais là pour le coup la prise en main
allez juste top après vous en douterez
une fois ouvert c'est le format tablette
et là on arrive vraiment dans tout autre
chose
là on tient à demain très clairement
mais par contre l'expérience est
vraiment sympa alors il ya un point et
je le dis dès maintenant c'est que vous
avez les haut parleurs qui situe la
premier côté haut parleurs la deuxième
haut-parleurs là ce qui fait que vous le
tenez comme ça quand vous regardez une
série un film ce que vous voulez et vous
jouez un jeu et non pas comme ça sans
quoi tout de suite vous boucher les haut
parleurs vous n'avez plus de sons et là
c'est quand même relativement bas l'eau
maintenant il ya un truc que je regrette
et que j'aime pas trop sur ce produit
sur ce smartphone est et je vous l'avais
déjà dit lorsque a été présenté c'est
cette encoches là haut
alors elle a un sens elle a une utilité
vous avez un double module photo je sais
c'est une toute première version il y
aura d'autres versions dans les années à
venir j'imagine que le design va évoluer
si vous regardez comme ça par exemple
voyez ça doit quand même haurogné alors
quand vous regardez une carte c'est pas
vraiment problématique mais lorsque vous
regarde un film ou pire vous joue un jeu
vidéo tout de suite c'est un peu moi ça
vous voyez par exemple sur paul j eh
bien voyez là j'ai la partie ici il ya
une partie qui est propre et 692 joueurs
donc ça reste un petit peu dommage
et là je vais bloquer le sont au niveau
des hauts parleurs du coup qu'est ce que
je fais je le prends je le retourne
comme ça hop et la part convoyer saviano
grignoter un petit peu mon bouton de
saut et c'est vrai que là tout de suite
c'est beaucoup moins égales par contre
j'ai du sommet par contre la voyait en
train de m'embêter et ça va ça c'est des
trucs un petit peu dommage mais bon
c'est pas totalement adapté sur ce type
d'expérience alors rendez vous se veut
une réflexion je trouvais que vous savez
le l'emplacement qu'on va avoir en bas
sur android pour pouvoir effectivement
va déjouer
que les boutons qui s'y était mal
positionné je trouvais ça très bizarre
est en fait en l'utilisant il faut que
c'est plutôt une bonne idée parce que ça
tombe très facilement sur le pouce droit
et c'est même plus simple que si vous le
mettez au milieu ce qui fait que ce qui
me paraissent est mal positionné au
début et au final plutôt malin je trouve
ça plutôt bien que ce soit là au final
c'est très facile à utiliser
je pense que j'aurais plus galérer à
bien le chercher au milieu faire des
grands écarts avec mon doigt donc comme
ça c'est plutôt bien vu
maintenant ce que j'ai regretté un petit
peu dessus c'est effectivement qu'on a
des grandes bordures noires on voit pas
très bien comme ça nous va se mettre
comme ça on a des grandes bordure ça je
pense que c'est des choses qui vont
pouvoir être peut-être améliorer
peut-être corriger ou pas ça dépend
effectivement la techno on voit un petit
peu la pliure de l'écran mais il faut
vraiment venir la chercher
on la sent légèrement sous le doigt mais
franchement à aucun moment ça m'a posé
de problème on trouve très facilement le
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour me
dire déverrouiller qui marche
parfaitement bien ici sur la tranche
donc ça c'est franchement cool je pense
que déjà l'année prochaine la techno qui
doit arriver chez samsung ce sont les
appareils photo intégrés sous l'écran
donc j'imagine que sur un projet comme
celui-là ça pareil ça sera intégré vous
aurez donc vos appareils sous l'écran on
devrait donc avoir un seul grand écran
avec l'appareil photo dessous donc là en
tout cas ça devrait être vraiment bien
maintenant il ya un autre truc c'est la
question ici de cet écran cet écran 4,6
pouces je le trouve intéressant
intéressant pour une raison principale
c'est qu'il vous sert pour vos
notifications il est petit il est assez
pratique dont sa force que vous avez
récemment vous ne voyez tout de suite
vous avez pas vu venir les je vais
l'ouvrir si nous quand vous êtes dans le
métro de transport en commun avait
beaucoup de monde à côté de vous vous
n'êtes pas forcément envie d'ouvrir ça
ça coûte quand même deux mille euros
voilà je ne sors pas partout j'ai
toujours été un peu discret même lorsque
je suis dans la rue pour balader avec
qui faire des photos je veux dire
vraiment dans ma poche c'est un
smartphone qu'on ne voit pas partout et
je suis pas toujours très à l'aise de me
balader avec donc le fait d'abord en
tout cas ce petit écran comme ça ça vous
permet de l'utiliser sans que les toits
que voit d'un côté un peu parano vient
qui veut ça mais je peux vous assurer
que je trouve ça rassurant vous
l'utilisez très bien lecteurs de sms
pour venir naviguer pour faire des
photos ça c'est vraiment très très très
pratique
à côté de ça j'aurais pu espérer que
samsung fasse quelque chose d'un peu
mieux un écran plus grand peut-être pour
l'année prochaine mais une fois de plus
on est sur un écran de notification né
sur un écran d'appoint sur l'écran de
confort on n'est pas sur un écran
d'utilisation concret de ce smartphone
l'écran concret du produit il est là on
a quand même accès à beaucoup
d'informations on est sur une résolution
de 1680 par 720 pixels
c'est assez bizarre effectivement de se
dire qu'on a un écran de 720 pixels sur
un smartphone à plus de 2000 euros comme
ça mais bon on s'y habitue vous avez
accès ici à tous et très pratique toutes
les infos sont là en fait c'est un coup
à prendre une fois vous avez l'habitude
de l'utiliser comme ça pour venir
chercher des petites choses rapidement
pour avoir accès à votre appareil photo
pour leur accès aux plages store pour
accès au téléphone passe un coup de fil
eh bien ça devient habituel et ça
dérange moins mais c'est vrai que tout
de suite on comprend des constituants
smartphone à plus de 2000 euros et bien
le fait d'avoir cessé grande bordure en
bas et en haut du bras pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils n'ont pas utilisé qu'un seul mais
les grands écrans je pense qu'on y
arrivera dans les années à venir
je pense surtout à l'écran va grandir
les choses vont évoluer c'est une v1
mais bon c'est déjà pas mal mais le truc
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est ça là
vous avez vraiment du confort pour
regarder des séries des films jouer et
ça c'est vraiment révolutionnaire
ce qui est vraiment impressionnant c'est
le confort qu'on vous allez dire
regarder des séries la joue mais une
vidéo sur netflix regarder ça c'est
vachement bien ce que vous êtes comme ça
alors là déjà vous êtes sur le forme un
petit peu standard vous venez cropper
ces trucs petit à petit peu on va dire
bon c'est pas forcément ça vous venez
quand même vachement vous met dans
l'image vous allez perdre sur les côtés
mais par contre ce qui est vachement
bien c'est le confort regardez-moi ça
vous avez un truc qui est énorme ça
tient dans mes deux mains vous avez un
vrai confort de visionnage et c'est ça
qui est vraiment génial et vous avez la
même chose sur youtube la seule
différence c'est que vous pouvez pas
venir zoomer vous pouvez pas c'est
strictement impossible donc ça c'est un
petit peu frustrant alors peut-être que
ça va être développée par youtube qui
vont venir corriger ce point il
améliorer mais c'est vrai que là voyez
j'ai un peu forcé médias demain ce ne
pas venir ou non je suis comme ça je
suis en plein écran et c'est pas
possible
à côté de ça et quand même un vrai
confort alors attention images et des
vidéos au format 16 9ème sur des vidéos
format 18/9 vous allez réduire encore un
petit peu sur le dessus donc ça pas
forcément mais le 16/9 marche quand même
pas trop mal
bon voilà ça c'est un petit peu des
points de regret mais je pense que c'est
la plénitude devenir complètement
s'adapter et si ce type de smartphone se
démocratise je pense que youtube et
d'autres éditeurs vont faire le boulot
pour que les bandes disparaissent en
haut et en bas je vous parle également
de confort sur les réseaux sociaux ou
regarder sur instagram comme c'est
vachement agréable là typiquement
regarder quand je regarde des photos
comme ça en grand c'est vraiment génial
j'en profite et ça joue ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment
de la même manière sur facebook regardez
vous voyez tout en grand c'est facile à
lire c'est extrêmement lisible et
réduire la fatigue oculaire ayant plus
qu'au final la réduits à regarder ici
vous avez le mode filtre de lumière
bleue que j'ai activé que venir un petit
peu jaunir c'est bien vous allez ce
raccourci juste là pour venir régler
l'opacité
vous le mettez comme vous voulez up the
l'activent son sac couleur après il ya
pas mal de petites options ici mais sans
une fois de plus ça marche aussi
parfaitement bien dolby et non ça c'est
cool pour l'expérience sonore faut dire
qu'avec cet écran en 1536 pixels par
2152 de 7 3 pouces vous avez franchement
de quoi faire et c'est là tout l'intérêt
de ce produit on part du principe que le
produit est démocratisée qu'on peut le
retrouver partout très facilement peut
utiliser sans aucun problème vous n'êtes
pas peur de sortir dans la rue ce qui
n'est pas encore mon cas aujourd'hui
eh bien vous l'utilisez google maps et
ça je trouve que une fois de plus c'est
un truc qui est vachement intéressant
très très très bien fait regardez moi le
confort là dessus est-ce que c'est pas
complètement dingue là vous vous baladez
vous avez vos de google maps à la main
vous perdez pas vous l'avez là comme ça
vaut regarder où est ce que vous êtes
il ya un vrai beau confort pc vraiment
tout l'intérêt de ce produit c'est le
confort de visionnage
rien que pour ça je mets une excellente
note là dessus à samsung pour
l'innovation
je vous dis ya des points à améliorer
mais si on prend expérience globale au
niveau du produit ça marche bien après
j'ai eu absolument aucun problème de
ralentissement j'installe dragon 855 12
giga de ram 512 il ya de stockage on
vous parlait franchement mettre dedans
avant qu'il commence un petit peu a
montré ses limites et vous avez une
grosse batterie de 4380 milliampères
heures alors on pourrait se poser la
question de la batterie
au final est-ce que la batterie elle
batelière et c'est là où ça devient
intéressant
là où on voit réellement les usages
parce que il ya un truc un prêt
fantasmes avec ce produit on va
l'imaginer que on l'a tout le temps
comme ça à lui mais à la main en
permanence en fait non c'est quand on se
dit je vais acheter ce produit est bien
j'y vais tout le temps lui mais j'ai
tout le temps et de sueur regarder des
séries 6 et ça alors plus le soir la
journée le général on travaille un peu
plus on fait plus de choc donc on les
plus à l'utiliser comme un smartphone
avec qui elle c'est cette petite écran
d'appoint pour tout ce qui va être sms
appels et compagnie cet écran là n'est
pas très grand et c'est pas lui qui va
consommer le plus le grand écran
l'intérieur année l'utiliser
il ya des moments vraiment dédié et
optimiser ce n'est qu'au début on nous
tout le temps et tout temps là dessus
c'est le gadget c'est cool mais au bout
d'un moment on régule un petit peu je
dirais son son utilisation on est un
petit peu moins là dessus tout le temps
à l'utiliser on va vraiment bien
utiliser quand vous avez réellement
besoin de dire vouloir regarder une
série naviguer sur les réseaux sociaux
l'état que pour chercher un contact
rapide pour aller passer un appel pour
envoyer un sms pour tout ce qui va être
là tâches courantes
vous utilisez cet écran là pour tout le
reste les réseaux sociaux les moments et
qui peu sympa et bien vous allez
utiliser cet écran l'a donc la question
d'autonomie pour moi elle est quand même
plutôt de bonnes je pense que deux jours
vous les avez mais une fois de plus ça
va dépendre de vos besoins ça va
dépendre de quelle façon vous vous allez
vous approprier ce smartphone est ce que
vous allez l'utilité d'une manière
excessive
peut-être qu'au début vous allez
beaucoup l'utiliser un peu mois après où
les trouver d'autres façons de
fonctionner mais en tout cas selon moi
la deux jours vous avez voilà sans aucun
problème après il ya les ligues matic
question l'appareil photo parce qu'on va
se lire sur ce smartphone live bien j'ai
pas moins de six appareils photos lequel
je veux utiliser alors vous allez voir
le tout en photo est assez simple on
utilise la caméra de celle fille assez
facilement 10 mégapixels lorsque vous
êtes à l'extérieur ça m'arrache vous
prenez en photo sa route plutôt bien à
l'arrière là vous avez trois capteurs
c'est la même chose que ce que vous y
retrouver sur les smartphones de samsung
de cette année ça marche bien ça fait de
très bonnes photos le rendu est vraiment
cool c'est vraiment vraiment hyper cool
et à l'intérieur on a ici deux appareils
photo de caméras ici et c'est là où ça
me paraît un peu moins évident vous êtes
pouvoir faire pourquoi pas celle fille
une fois tout ouvert comme ça mais s'il
ouvert comme ça je ne vois pas trop
l'intérêt de faire un siècle il peut
être plus à ce moment-là ce que vous
allez discuter avec des amis peut-être
sur skype sur what's app sur messenger
là il ya plus son sens mais vous prendre
en photo la non la plus pour la
visioconférence avec des amis ça marche
pour faire un selphy vous prenez axa ça
marche bien de ça marche vraiment bien à
l'intérieur ça marche également les
capteurs arrière marche vraiment bien
vous avez la caméra normale c'est déjà
un grand temps que vous avez un ultra
grand temps 16 mégapixels et puis vous
avez un téléobjectif avec un zoom x 2
qui marche bien voilà les photos sont de
très bonne qualité vous connaissez
travail de samsung ça marche bien il est
très polyvalent je pense pas qu'on
utilise et les six caméras tout le temps
je dis une fois de plus et de caméras à
l'intérieur c'est un petit peu moins
salée
sinon le rendu
bien on se dirait qu'on m'a pas ça pour
avoir ce photophone les croyez moi que
le savoir-faire de samsung est maîtrisée
ici en termes de photos aussi je vous
montre quelques photos à vous de me dire
comment vous les trouvez ce que
donneront ces jeux là on y sent
l'appareil photo principal témoin
principal dans le métro ou en
douteraient à paris ici on est sur le
zoom x 2 donc là le métro bouge donc
c'est pas ça qui a coté un petit peu
flou
là vous avez le grand-angle ultra grand
angle qui marche bien je n'aurais sur
l'appareil photo normale la cellule très
grand danger là on est sur le zoom x de
sened c'est clair ça marche très très
bien
photo nuit on est là sur l'appareil
normal on a du détail c'est pas cramé
même au niveau des lumières c'est
vraiment bien on voit un peu de ciel
ici en haut on voit bien les tailles au
niveau des landes ya un vrai beau savoir
faire zoom x 2 et je te raconte alors
luttera grand-angle la nuit pour moi
c'est un peu moins ça donc vraiment
utiliser deux jours là c'est pareil vous
avez l'appareil photo normale de nuit ça
marche bien c'est une photo que j'ai
fait avec la caméra de celle ficelles
que vous avez ici à la vente c'est une
photo de nuit dont il ya beaucoup moins
de lumière leur ont eu tout de suite est
beaucoup moins qualitatif là on est pris
avec cet appareil là pareil je suis ici
pas bluffé la nuit vous l'utilisez pas
ça ne marche pas très très bien et là on
est le jour alors le jour c'est
merveilleux et une vraie belle maîtrise
de sa mission ça marche très très bien
l'ultra grand angle mais c'est les
objectifs le zoom x deux pareils on
prend aussi un être bien les détails des
nuages fil ultra grand angle ça marche
vraiment bien classée la caméra de celle
fit placer la caméra intérieure voyez ça
marche bien
caméra normale ultra grand angle une
fois deux c'est bon c'est juste ça
marche on est donc sur un smartphone qui
est vraiment innovant qui propose
quelque chose de nouveau une nouvelle
expo donc on n'a pas trop ses repères
quand on prend quand on commence à
l'utiliser c'est vrai qu'on se dit alors
à temps quelle caméra je veux utiliser
surtout pour la partie selphy quel écran
je vais utiliser à quel moment et puis
au final les choses se font assez
naturellement et on comprend comment ça
marche et surtout on se l'approprié
c'est vraiment là tout l'intérêt d'un
produit comme celui là l'intérêt de
nouvelles techno tout son image trop
l'intérêt ce que je vais vraiment
utiliser ce grand écran au milieu et
croyez moi qu'une fois qu'on ya goûté on
a du mal à s'en passer alors je devrais
m'en passer parce que c'est un produit
prêt de la part de samsung donc il
repart 1,8 a mis un gros bisou je dirais
très bientôt mais en tout cas je suis
très content d'avoir pu le tester et
grand merci à samsung de me l'avoir
prêté je trouve ça vraiment intéressant
je continue je signe et je persiste pour
moi les smartphones pliable sont lavés
en tout cas une des
évolution possible du smartphone le
smartphone tel que vous le connaissez
aujourd'hui va être amené à évoluer
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup d' usage qui
vont se crée avec des choses comme ça
échoue c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
intéressant une fois de plus ce produit
n'est pas parfait et il est assez un
parfait mais c'est une v1 il a fallu à
sortir je trouve en tout cas plutôt bien
plutôt encourageante
j'ai hâte de voir ce que va nous sortir
ça me fout là dessus en 2020 et croyez
moi il va y avoir beaucoup d'innovations
vers des choses très intéressantes
a vous de me dire maintenant ce que vous
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
vous décrire ça est ce que vous trouvez
ça intéressant je sais c'est toujours un
peu frustrant parce que vous l'avez pas
tester donc dès lors qu'on ne teste pas
on a du mal à pouvoir se prononcer on
peut se faire une idée sur le principe
est bon voilà
mais croyez moi le truc est vraiment
intéressant quand vous réussissez pas à
gommer les points négatifs
le design amélioré le rendre un peu plus
léger peut-être un peu plus fin croyez
moi c'est grand écran sont vraiment
extraordinaires et moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires et quant à
nous on se retrouve dès demain vous
embrasse ciao